tim anderson led the american league
with 45 runs scored he had 67 hits and
10 home runs with a 322 batting average
and 886 ops
this is tim's first silver slugger award
he won the louisville slugger silver
battle award in 2019 as the american
league batting champion when he hit for
a 3 35 average
abreu led the american league with 76
hits 60 rbis 148 total bases and a 617
slugging percentage he had 19 home runs
a 317 batting average and a 987 ops
this is hosea brayu's third silver
slugger he also won in 2014 and 2018.
congratulations to eloy kim and jose on
your silver slugger awards
and thank you to louisville slugger the
official band of major league baseball
carlos rodon has been scratched due to
an upset stomach
that means dallas kikel steps in
so now cesar hernandez steps
and in one out into left center robert
took a look back at the fence he leaps
he's got it
that's a gold glove play by louise
robert
as he robs hernandez of extra bases and
he's grimacing just a little bit
hopefully he's all right tristan
mckenzie will be on the mound for
cleveland tonight
tristan mckenzie has been a prize
prospect for cleveland for some time now
adam eaton will lead it off he's back in
chicago left-handed hitting right
fielder now the wind and the next
offering
and it swung on and missed went with a
change up away at 88 miles an hour and
he strikes out adam eaton
that'll bring up luis robert
who's already made a fine defensive play
and
that's why he won the gold glove
in 2020.
now the 2-2
and it's swung on and missed ran the
fastball in on the hands of robert
and that is out number two and a couple
of strikeouts and
right now the milo's tipped up to 94.
two down no score here's last year's mvp
jose abreu
now the payoff
swing and a miss on an elevated fastball
what an inning for mckenzie strikes out
the side the indians and socks scoreless
after one so the indians get the lead
off man aboard in the second and now
eddie rosario batting fifth
will bat in the second inning no score
runner on
now the set by kykel
and the pitch
swung on skied in the air fairly deep
left center robert back track at the
wall it's gone
eddie rosario a left-handed
hitter gets a two-run homer off a tough
southpaw to left center and the indians
have a two-nothing lead here in ending
number two
rosario with his second home run of the
campaign
so the leadoff man adam eaton comes up
with two men on
one strike on him
and he drives this one
deep right
three to two white sox as eaton does it
again
wow
another big home run
from the right fielder out of me leading
the team in home runs with three of them
two down for jose abreu who struck out
his first time up three to two socks
payoff pitch
check swing did he go looked like he did
yep on the appeal at first bill miller
brings up jose abreu fifth strikeout for
mckenzie yes monty grand all up now
switch hitter
batting from the left side against the
right-hander mckenzie
grondell since the 2015 season
leads all major league catchers in home
runs and runs driven in pitch to it
called strike three at the knees on the
inside corner
grandal caught looking side retired good
bounce back inning for mckenzie
friend mel reyes elevated to the cleanup
spot tonight
he's been hit by a pitch and struck out
base is still loaded but now one down
and the next delivery
reyes sends one high in the air fairly
deep center playable for robert in front
of the track makes the catch tagging
scoring the tying run is yuchang tagging
going to third is luplow staying at
first is hernandez and fran mill reyes
has delivered again
he now has a team high
eight runs batted in
and the indians have tied the game at
three
they still have runners at the corners
but now there are two men out for eddie
rosario
who hit a two-run homer to left center
off dallas keikl back in the second
inning
the set and pitch
and it swung on line toward left near
the line moving over williams makes the
shoulder high catch boy another
well-struck ball off the bat of rosario
the indians tie it up but they have
bases loaded nobody out base to stay
loaded game stays tied and here's
yasmani grand doll
switch enter batting left-handed
quantrill's ready here it comes
and it's swung on grounded toward first
fielded by chang to second one relay by
rosario and a double play
and cal cuantro screaming as he comes
off the mound what a job by the kid
jordan luplow steps in two for three
for the indian center fielder tonight
delivers swung on and missed
hoyer sets him down a big leg kick
afterward
ball game remains tied at three it would
be roberto perez
with two out and a man on second
here in the ninth
hoyers had to work real hard
against roberto perez
with josh naylor at second here's the
3-2 he got him foul tip into the mitt
hoyer's got him
and the white sox keep it tied at three
and now williams
broken bat roller
throw to second and it hits the runner
here comes madrigal
and they win it
wow the white sox win it 4-3
the white sox win it in the bottom of
the ninth
4-3 they stopped the indians four-game
win streak